okay now we are a long journey to wales
what we love to do is
drive through
for a bite to eat
hello
[Music]
hi guys hi how are you
i'm good thank you good i'm very well
thank you um could i ask for a
vanilla
latte please um
do you
do you have any of those um amazing
toasters
we do have a cheesecloth here
and is that the um ham and cheese jamie
oliver toasty from the shell garage
no oh
that just said that toasties were this
way
um what's in the toasty
thank you
does it have a cheese one is that the
hickory smoked ham
right is there any tomato in there
sir
hello it's got mustard mustard is it
english or french mustard sorry
american i'm not oh i'm allergic to the
american one um
and
the veggie new york deli style sandwich
is that a jeremy oliver sandwich or is
that the starbucks sandwich no we don't
do anything
well the shell garage said you did
um did you take do you do takeaways
sorry do you do takeaways
take away oh what's 10 take away from
100
i'll stick to the hickory ham cheese
toasty please
could i have extra cheese in that toasty
please
for you is there any chance of having
some extra cheese in that hickory ham
the pre-made i'm afraid pre-made
okay um no i'll just i'll take the
normal hickory ham cheese toasty please
thank you
that's it thank you
thank you
no extra cheese
that's a bit naughty
no pickles
here we are
hello
how are you
thank you there's a quick look
[Music]
it's only toasted one side
i asked for no mustard
[Music]
take care guys
bye bye
it looks like something out of harry
snotter
take care guys
be good
is that english or french mustard
american
[Music]
as you do
on drive-thru
a long trip down to cornwall
and uh great coffee
starts here right
british smoke bacon back
i'm very good thank you how are you
excellent gordon your costa right we are
indeed yeah excellent thank you sam um
may i have a british smoke uh bacon back
yes of course that were testable brown
sauce today um is the ketchup heinz it
is indeed excellent and is the hp hp
it is indeed excellent could i have hp
inside and catch up on the outside
please so it's actually served in little
sachets right i might give you one of
each on the side i'll take a sachet of
each and where the bait where's the
bacon from
i'll just pass it with my man it's not
100 sure i'm afraid okay amanda thank
you
[Music]
i'm not sure on the exact location that
there is british sauce bacon british
sauce bacon and there's any chance of
having an extra rasher please i'm afraid
not that is actually our last bacon back
we've got today unfortunately okay and
how big is the bat
it's probably a good handful good size
so proper sized bat yeah
i'll take that thank you and do your
takeaways
yeah
um can you tell me what 25 is taken away
from 100
75. well done bingo we'll see in a
minute thank you very much
hi how are you how are you i'm good nice
to see alice
so we've got the last back of the day
yeah with hp and ketchup thank you
and two coffees please thank you and how
many baps you sell a day how many peps
do you sell a day
a good few boxes
wow
56 wow that's a lot of bats man jesus
thank you
excellent and and no extra bacon
thank you
just checking
[Music]
is that it
is that
2 pound 90 for that
how much is
to do the that
how much is how much is that
that is three pounds for that for one
ratio of bacon unfortunately so yeah
jesus christ big boy
you can buy half a pound of bacon down
the local butchers for one pound fifty
don't i know that i'm fully aware and
it's the grill on bottom it's all done
in like uh like a microwave oven so
they're not grilling the
bacon comes in pre-packaged can we just
you don't microwave bacon
how many times i told you
it's all got the fountain
please i'll take the roll take the bacon
back
tell mr costa to get a grill for
christmas i will i will pass it on thank
you that way i'll stop grilling you
oh my god
[Music]
give me your ears
give me your ears
oh jesus what are you doing
oh god
you've gone rogue
what are you idiot sandwich louder idiot
sandwich
take care
don't forget the grill please
jesus christ
you cannot microwave bacon
you've got to grill it